Godzilla king of the monsters was
directed by Michael Dougherty and stars
Kyle Chandler Millie Bobby Brown Vere
Farmiga Ken Watanabe tons of talent in
the film some holdovers from Gareth
Edwards Godzilla film that came out in
2014 but this one continues that film
story as well as branching off of Kong
Skull Island and in this film Godzilla
faces off against a considerable amount
of monsters while some humans on the
ground tried to do some stuff with the
military so in other words it's a
Godzilla movie I've loved Godzilla ever
since my mom brought home the American
re-edited version with Raymond Burr
included from the library when I was a
little kid and in 1998 when I was 10
years old I thought Roland Emmerich's
Godzilla was the best thing I had ever
seen gratefully since then I have
developed a brain I think and I really
liked Gareth Edwards Godzilla in 2014
when I first saw it in subsequent read
watches I don't like it as much as I did
at the time largely because of one of
the biggest complaints with that film
which was not enough Godzilla why are
you holding back on Godzilla totally
understand those complaints the makers
of this film definitely took that
criticism and said you know what we're
just gonna have a lot of Godzilla and a
whole bunch of other monsters too this
movie has most of the famous Godzilla
monsters and if you saw the trailer you
know that already and they're amazing
the monster sequences in the movie the
fights the battles the spectacle that
come with these creatures is draw
dropping it's easily the best part of
the movie and it's highly satisfactory
whenever stuff with them is going on
unfortunately there's a lot of stuff
with some really boring ass people -
they clearly took the criticism the
first film had and ran with it and they
gave us a lot more of the monsters you
see gods a lot and often and that's
going to please fans but you also have a
lot of time with some people and if you
thought the human beings in Gareth
Edwards Godzilla weren't fleshed out
well you are going to be bored to tears
with the people in this movie because
they are just there to give exposition
just about every scene in between a
monster fight is just people in a room
telling a story sometimes complete with
what appears to be a PowerPoint
presentation there's like two sequences
in this movie where characters just have
images stored and ready in multiple wind
to open at just the right moment as they
narrate over this image a great story
this happens constantly throughout this
movie it's to me a big disappointment as
someone who loves Godzilla I have yet to
see that perfect Godzilla movie since
the original it just hasn't happened yet
even though I I love this scope of
Gareth Edwards film Gareth Edwards
really understood the size the massive
proportions of these creatures this new
film is not as beautiful looking the
shots aren't as impressive the sequences
with Godzilla and all the other
creatures feel less impactful because
since there's more of them they feel
less precious you could talk about the
original Jurassic Park and how they
perfectly spaced out the sequences with
the dinosaurs but that movie also has
amazing characters likable characters
and so you care about the humans and you
actually want to see what they're doing
and the dinosaurs are like this awesome
side thing that's so cool but
also it has en Malcolm this
movie doesn't have anybody like that it
just has a lot of competent actors who
are giving fine performances as they
read bad dialogue I talked to my friend
after this movie and we both agreed that
the script felt like first draft it
couldn't possibly be they had five years
to work on this movie five years one of
the biggest complaints with the MCU
films or the DC EU films or the Star
Wars films nowadays is that they're not
given enough time to work on each movie
that they're they're having to rush out
these movies in the theaters to get
people to come and see them and not
forget about the franchise because it's
real time nowadays you know what I mean
they had five years to work on this film
and I do not understand why the
characters are robots I don't understand
why the story is ludicrous
characters make choices in this movie
with the end goal of monster chaos all
over the world yeah we all want to see
that but wouldn't it be nice if we got
to that by some logical means something
that makes sense I don't want to get
into spoilers the films not out yet and
I'm not going to but the way this film
goes about getting these things released
is insane it just seemed like the
writers really wanted to get these
creatures loose so they could have a
bunch of fight sequences in a city and
not care about logic reasoning or
anything that makes sense and that was
so disappointing to me because yet again
we have a movie that is essentially
saying hey monsters are cool
right
don't you love Godzilla yeah we do okay
but let's also have half this movie just
be filled with mindless robot characters
that you don't give a about a list
actors appear on a webcam to introduce a
weapon that is shot and then is
instantly disregarded and never
discussed again people die left and
right no spoilers and and you never feel
like there's any mourning you never feel
like you're catching up with these
people they just don't feel like they're
real they don't feel like human beings
because the movie is so laser focused on
having enough of the monsters that they
seem to have completely forgot about the
importance of story and character it's
only the two most imperative aspects of
a film it's like they took that
criticism from the first film and said
okay we're gonna give you a lot more
Godzilla and other creatures but we're
also gonna make everyone else even worse
and so it almost equals out to the
problems people have with the first one
yeah there wasn't as much Godzilla but
at least it had Bryan Cranston
in it for a while this movie doesn't
have any character that I latched on to
maybe Milly Bobby Brown who is really
good in the movie but I don't even
remember what her name in the movie was
because she's just daughter in distress
for the whole movie she barely does
anything of Merit and there's a central
conflict between her and her parents
that is glossed over and barely explored
it could have been so much better than
it was this was a massive disappointment
to me because yeah you get a lot of coal
monster fights and the visuals are
spectacular and if that's all you want
to see okay go have fun but if you would
like to have a story that's cohesive
that makes sense with characters that
feel like human beings that have a path
that have real motivation that don't
change their motivation every other
scene because the script really needs
them to be at Point a
point B for the monstrous to do this
thing then you're gonna be disappointed
like I was with this movie I thought it
could have been a lot better and as a
massive Godzilla fan I left disappointed
I'm gonna give Godzilla king of the
monsters a c-minus I don't actually know
what fans are gonna think this movie
because I just don't know what Godzilla
fans want to see because there's so many
Godzilla fans the people who
specifically only like the Japanese
Godzilla films watch the Godzilla movies
because of their satire and their
political commentary but the American
Godzilla films they just want to see
Godzilla eat a building and like punch a
monster
they don't give a about anything
else sometimes but I gotta be honest
sometimes this movie did remind me of a
Dean Devlin film if you don't know who
that is he produced the 98 Godzilla and
a lot of those like disaster type movies
that came out during that time period
and the dialogue in this movie and the
way things are set up the way weapons
are set up and characters are just
thrown away left and right it reminded
me of that but I was shocked by to be
honest guys thank you so much as always
for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon I'm curious to know
what you guys think of the new film as
always thanks again for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you